does with Russia et it may be a habit
that still preoccupied with gathering
strength Russian state would not be able
to stand in the way of such plans
cooperation between Poland Ukraine and
Romania would create a favorable
position for the power projection by
American North European allies in case
it was needed in the south and southeast
it does not seem impossible to imagine a
bridge composed of British Norwegian
Danish polish and Ukrainian elements
linking the Atlantic with the Black Sea
and father on through Georgia and
Azerbaijan with the custom see in a
product thus outlined Poland and Ukraine
would both became sub-regional crucial
participants in a larger strategic
counsel the perspective of such
participation even if only in due time
could give the necessary support for the
pro-western politicians in the Ukraine
support that is much needed when
building an alternative for the
dominating Russian influence in their
own country the possible future to draw
NATO into active political engagement in
the region of the greater Middle East
may bring an end to the significance of
the pact and subsequently a policy
evaluation in the United States with
Washington unilaterally seeking
agreement opportunities with a global
scale score with such terms it seems
probable that grant work would be laid
that out for the network of bilateral
agreements initiated by Washington with
the aim of establishing the missile
defense system with global range Japan
Australia several European states
including Poland might offer the
territories to host the system with the
significant degree of probability it may
be anticipated the part from Poland
participated countries would include
among others Romania
variant kalki it would be the interest
of Poland to convince Washington to
incorporate Ukraine in the system
hopefully this time no one in Kiev will
be tempted to make money on the
secretary salt called sugars one way or
the other foreign should see as its
strategic goal being in a defensive
lines together with Ukraine and the
united states apart from everything else
membership in a given organization often
fathers make easier bilateral relations
brussels as i mentioned is not
considering ukraine for membership into
you leaving it out of the union is not
the polish entered a means of
establishing special provisions for the
cooperation between the you and kiev
might be designing and implementing the
details of new initiative for example
southeastern dimension modeled on the
northern that mention being presently
realized by the european commission
encompassing the Northern European and
the Baltic region just at the latter was
initiated by the Finns seeking
assistance in the difficult relations
with Russia the new initiative
originated by Poland and Romania and the
southeast might bring Ukraine and the
caucus closer to the European Union
assuring constant for this project
within the Union institutions will not
be easy and it will become even harder
once the financial details needs to be
decided on nevertheless perspective
offering independent active present for
the EU in parallel to the Americans in
the region of the black and the Caspian
Sea might convince the you EU net
contributors to participate in this
political and economic initiative well
being undertaken in power within the EU
along with the political and military
framework of the alliance with with the
United States may convince the
politicians in fear to discard the
policy of a fees
toward the Russian Federation the above
glance has no guarantee of success yet
abandoning them will with near certainty
guarantee that in 10 years Ukraine will
sign a new pairs of agreement with the
Moscow which by that time will be well
advanced on the path of regaining its
power I was asked to give a vision of
the future I let myself to detach it
from the present-day relations between
Poland and Ukraine I did so only because
i do not see their present shape leading
to anything significant significantly
advantages they lack of strategic vision
with the domination of petty trader of
taking from one side considering to a
cement or a new turn for a monument a
python pipeline in newton falls